hello everybody out there i am colson
baker aka machine gun kelly
i am one of the directors and writers of
downfalls high
i am sydney sweeney i play scarlet i am
here
with coulson machine gun kelly to do the
buzzfeed
quiz to find out how well we know each
other yeah
oh it's so loud
[Music]
what is a must-have in my dressing room
well i know i had to convince you to
stay late on your last day of filming
by letting your dog be in the scene
because i asked i i needed to get
one shot and we i made you wait so long
because we had to squeeze in these
performance shots you were like i'll
stay but the only condition is that like
my dog needs to be in a scene so we like
inserted a whole
narrative about the dog
apart and so i mean i would guess like
we need
organic doggy snacks so your dog is like
healthy
and well non-gmo live
and then for you maybe like almonds for
protein
maybe like sour punch straws or sour
skittles i'll give it to you i
add candy and then a tank can be in the
trailer i'm good
i don't even know if i had a dressing
room i was just like with i was running
around with like a clipboard and
headphones the whole time like
either you would have to have like your
guitar or you always had a
like a piece of paper that's it yeah the
guitar that is my dressing room
guitar your favorite snack at craft
services i feel like
i never saw you eat you're so busy
i drank so much coffee and didn't eat
anything i don't i didn't
you know how every craft services has
welsh's fruit snacks are you the type to
grab welch's fruit snacks
yeah me too i was gonna ask like what's
my go-to activity between
filming scenes but i was just freaking
out and just jittery off coffee
and like your go-to activity was to jump
around
and make sure everyone was okay and
make sure that everything was just put
together you were like you didn't have
any down time
for an activity in between i think i
asked you if you were okay like eight
thousand times a day like every five
minutes like
do you need anything should i just go
get you food myself right now like did
it not come yet jesus christ
i like love to imagine that eat as
peaceful and tranquil and
centered as you are that like when i'm
gone and you're in your trailer that
you're just like
that [ __ ] crazy that like when the door
closes and i walk away that like you
turn on just like
the loudest screamo music i've ever
heard in my life i maybe won't even ask
you if i'm correct i'm just going to
assume
that little part of me is right a
previous project that they were
a part of i mean it's hard to not guess
yours when you're
dominating the world with euphoria so i
i mean
if i don't get that correct i probably
live in a rock
like patrick from spongebob we did big
time adolescence together
yes which also was the next question
which was the first time we met syracuse
new york
big time adolescence i mean me and pete
were kind of super
disliked by the globe at that point and
like you were
really nice to both of us the first day
i showed up to set you and pete were
dancing on top of the trailers
oh my god yes yes i remember that
walk in and you guys are literally like
tattooing each other i'm like okay this
is like the coolest that i've ever been
on
he gave me the worst tattoo i gotta show
you guys he tattooed loco on me but it
looks like it says coco
is that a latte oh my goodness is that a
lot of
oh no but that's the funniest guess of a
tattoo i've ever had that's really funny
and it should be a latte because i'm
obsessed with coffee okay your age i
mean
i know that your birthday i want to say
was in april because i just missed your
birthday
yes you're like 30 30 i am 30.
i know how old you are because casting
you in a movie
you should probably know that so you are
23 years old
your birthday astrological sign well you
know mine i'm not really into the whole
astrology
thing so i don't really know signs as
well as i should
okay what like if i gave you a hint
would you could you guess if i gave you
a hint via hand signs
no i just don't know boris yeah okay
well give me a hint
for hand signs i think my sign is like
the lady i don't know this stuff either
is there's an animal or it's a lady
okay virgo i would have never known
coffee order i mean you like lattes
right
love lattes love like just like straight
up black coffee like
nitro coal brew i like straight to the
point caffeine
punches are you a tea or coffee person i
only drink water
yeah dude your diligence is crazy you're
kind of like yoda
only drinking water is one step closer
to yoda than most of us
okay middle name is it colson actually
your middle name
no i don't have a middle name everyone
always messes up thinking because
wikipedia
put my uncle's first name as my first
name
my name is coulson baker i always wanted
to add a middle name i don't know what
it would be
maybe it should be danger okay you
either have a super old school middle
name
like deborah i would i definitely have
an old school middle name oh you do okay
so
i was going gonna say that or like
hippie eccentric is your middle name
margaret's it's bernie it's my great
grandma's name
yo that's it yeah i like it
your hometown why do i feel like you're
either from
east coast or like texas i'll give it
away i'm from cleveland
okay my guess for you would be illinois
no i mean i go there a lot but
washington which washington
there's only one washington state trick
question okay
um favorite musician is there's like a
band like arcade fire or something like
that
i definitely like arcade fire i think
that because we're such in a creative
space like
how can you choose a favorite you can't
our generation shouldn't really have to
i'm a fan of being like
really into artists and not just songs
because i feel like our generation is
like
super song savvy but not really banned
fan
mania which i wish it would go back to
there's so much talent out there like i
can't choose one person
facts well i mean obviously mine is
britney spears so just like
next next question your favorite track
from tickets to my downfall i mean i
feel like you
have to like them all right i love them
all me and you talked about one
specifically do you remember which one
it was
lonely lonely for sure yeah
is that which is that is that your
favorite off of the off of the album
lonely okay
i want to say to like anyone watching
like i sent sydney the album before it
was out
and she believed in it before it was out
there was no way to see if it was gonna
be something great like you just
believed it and i think that's really
cool
thank you when you brought it to me i
was like this is just so
like no one's done something like this
and i believe in you as an artist
and clearly a director and you're just
let's go
favorite scene to shoot about filming
downfall hi watching you
be the doctor like you have to get oh my
god the operator
yes oh my god that was my favorite i
loved that favorite game growing up
yeah dude my favorite improv of the
whole movie was do you like airplanes
i hate airplanes and what do you want to
be when you grow up
dead like both of those were improv they
weren't in the script i thought it was
so sick and then obviously travis's son
saying that he was better than travis
blocker is hilarious
our audio department was like you guys
have to hold up on you know talking
there's a plane passing by
and i was like so frantic i'm like i
don't care just talk about the airplanes
talk about the airplanes and then chase
was like do you like airplanes
she was just like i [ __ ] hate
airplanes
a surprising thing you learned about
them actually i honestly learned how
talented you
are as more of a like directorial
position you really brought your vision
to life
and guided everyone in the way that you
wanted and i think that
that was something that i truly learned
about you i want to direct
like a full feature so bad if i if i was
to say anything i learned about you
i mean i think your talent clearly like
preceded you and continues to precede
you so it's hard for me to like act like
i was
surprised by that my favorite actors
were the ones who
do the things with tarantino and then
also do stuff that's like for the
culture
throw it up in the air and however it
comes down is what it is and i just
thought that was so
so punk of you and so cool and like
you're an artist you're not like for the
names for the fame
it's rare and really cool and like this
hit a completely different demographic
than even i was expecting that it would
hit
i got 11 out of 15. okay i got
9 out of 15 right sydney sweetie is the
winner
everyone go watch downfalls high it's
out now go enjoy
thank you guys bye coulson
you